hi my name is Serena hurry and I'm a
master students in electrical
engineering and computer science and for
my master's research I've been working
in the networks at MIT group in Cecil
the main technology that our group works
on is a device called Y track which is a
wall-mounted IOT device that uses radio
signals to monitor various things of
people in the environment such as their
breathing sleeping and walking patterns
now in order to actually use this device
and deploy it in people's homes there
are two main components that first need
to be configured which are connecting
the device to a wireless network for
internet connectivity and specifying the
boundaries in which the device is
allowed to collect data unfortunately
the pre-existing methods for configuring
both of these components was very
difficult to use required experts and
was not always reliable so for my
project I built the first configuration
system for Y track for both wireless
connectivity and physical boundaries and
I focused on making the system easy to
use not requiring experts as well as
being reliable and robust and as of now
we've successfully deployed the wireless
configuration system in over a dozen
homes with successful and positive
feedback and we are currently in the
process of running user studies for the
configuration for physical boundaries